when something happens it is always
you three if you think the golden trio
got dealt a bad hand on screen
wait until you hear what the cast and
crew of harry potter had to deal with
while filming
from serious onset accidents to the
personal struggles of some actors
filming harry potter wasn't always a
casual stroll through hogwarts
what the bloody hell was that all about
it wasn't just harry who had to find a
way to stay underwater for a whole
hour in the goblet of fire daniel
radcliffe had to do it without the help
of neville's gillyweed
in order to get the second task of the
triwizard tournament done
dan trained in huge water tanks for
weeks with professionals so when the
time came he'd be able to do as much
acting as possible underwater but one
day
things went wrong when dan confused some
of the hand signals
who knew a thumbs up could also mean
help i'm literally drowning
it was almost quite frustrating because
the communication is so hard we hear
about how emma watson is literally
hermione in real life but we never talk
about how similar ron and rupert are
especially when it comes to their
playful personalities but rupert's humor
got him into quite a bit of trouble on
set
from day one the actor was prone to
bursting out into laughing fits that had
the entire cast
constantly re-filming the same scenes
over and over
we wouldn't be surprised if rupert ever
pulled a why so serious line as a joke
it might have set the filming back a tad
but it seems like everyone took his
breaking character as a moment to just
laugh things off
sorry just listen to how fondly the
casting crew remember the experience
he just laughs all the time you can't
stop him once he starts
hogwarts might not have been your
ordinary school but they still had to
deal with mundane problems like
lice breakouts while filming the chamber
of secrets the entire cast and crew had
to be checked and treated for life
after they found out some cast members
were infected they were forced to pause
filming for an
entire day while they dealt with all the
cases looks like the basilisk wasn't the
only creature to worry about on set
that year we completely agree with ron's
fear of spiders but we're not gonna lie
light might be the creepy crawly we want
to stay away from
it's disgusting imagine having to go to
school and
work and still getting assigned extra
homework that's what happened to the
golden trio at the start of the prisoner
of azkaban
new director alfonso quaron had the
three young actors write character
essays to make sure they
understood harry hermione and ron
completely they each had to turn in
basically an
autobiography that explained how they
entered the wizarding world and how
their characters have grown
since they were 11. whilst the three of
them seemed oddly okay with the whole
situation
there was something that had dan pretty
annoyed about the whole
essay thing i i felt really so pleased
with myself
we all know filming a movie takes
intense dedication
we're talking hours and hours on set so
can we really blame
13 year old tom felton for sneaking
sweets onto the set for long filming
days
the young actor admitted he used to hide
snacks in the pockets of his robes
during the first films
i don't know i used to stuff a lot of
chocolates and sweets inside the robe
his technique caught on with the other
actors and soon the costume department
was finding
leftover snacks in all of the robes
rumor has it that was the reason the
pockets of the costume robes were sewn
shut in the later films we probably
would have done the same imagine being
tempted by all the prop food that lined
the table of the great hall
ron's right harry you're gonna need your
strength today if you thought watching
the battle of hogwarts unfold in the
deathly hallows was heartbreaking
wait until you find out what happened to
the actual hogwarts set
it burned down for real during the
filming of the deathly hallows one of
the special effects malfunctioned on set
and caused a fire they had been filming
shots at hogwarts but something went
wrong with one of the pyrotechnics
luckily none of the cast was on set when
it happened but they had to rebuild
everything that had gotten destroyed the
damage apparently cost
100 000 euros that's over 120 thousand
dollars
we can't imagine how catastrophic that
must have been such a pity
growing up in the spotlight isn't easy
just ask the entire harry potter cast
whether it be how self-conscious they
were being on camera during puberty or
feeling like they lost their childhood
in some way
almost all the actors have spoken about
the struggle but in dan's case his
struggle with the spotlight turned into
some
unhealthy coping mechanisms during the
filming for a half-blood prince he
suffered from substance abuse
he's admitted that although he never
drank on set he'd still sometimes be
intoxicated when filming rolled around
the next morning it was all because he
was trying to escape the feeling of
being watched
take a look the quickest way of
forgetting about the fact that you were
being watched was to
get very drunk we couldn't imagine
anyone else but emma watson filling the
shoes of hermione granger but there was
a point in time when we might have had
to explore that
in the middle of the franchise emma was
ready to give up her role in harry
potter and it was because her schedule
was totally clashing with her education
she had dreams of going to college and
being hermione was making that extremely
difficult
luckily the producers were able to
figure everything out they did have to
rework her entire filming schedule but
of course
it was worth it in the end she finished
the franchise and graduated from brown
university in 2014
talk about her real-life hermione i
think we had a bad influence on her
walking into the great hall alongside
harry for the first time was
well magical to say the least with its
towering ceiling intimidating
head table and falling candles okay well
we never actually got to see the candles
fall
but they did before they brought the
great halls floating candles to life in
the editing room they tried using real
lit candles but as you've probably
guessed that didn't go too well
the candles burned through the strings
that were supporting them and they fell
on the actor's heads
the only shot they ended up getting with
real candles is the first scene of the
first years walking into the great hall
for the sorting ceremony
in the sorcerer's stone good offender
[Applause]
you'll be pleased to know that the
hogwarts express is a real train and
we're not just talking about the mock
version at universal studios
that means when the production wasn't
using the train it had to be stored at a
depot
for the most part that worked out except
for the two times that it didn't
in 2003 a group of teens spray painted
the outside of the train cars
then in 2007 people went as far as to
smash in the windows of the train
luckily they were able to get it cleaned
and repaired both times so it could get
its moment to shine in each film
our hearts break just thinking about the
train being ruined it's basically an
actual character at this point
it wasn't just the stunt doubles that
got injured on the set of harry potter
while filming the order of the phoenix
neville's actor matthew lewis suffered a
pretty bad injury
while the cast was filming the intense
scene in the ministry of magic
helena bonham carter as bellatrix put
her wand in matthew's ear
matthew happened to move at the same
time she did it and it resulted in him
rupturing his eardrum
of course the whole ordeal was an
accident helena said
i thought i could brandish the wand like
a sort of q-tip sort of
torture it matthew took no hard feelings
for what happened and even tried to
prevent helena from feeling bad by
hiding how bad he was actually hurt
well done daniel radcliffe wasn't the
only actor who suffered mentally during
the filming of the movies devin murray's
character sheamus
was happy and go lucky even if he spent
a lot of his scenes
accidentally blowing things up
but off-screen devin was dealing with
some major depression
it got to the point where his life was
at risk take a listen to what he had to
say about it
i'd gone into the doctors into the
hospital they said they don't know
how long it can last for despite the
mishaps the cast and crew experience
throughout those 10 years we're glad
they were still able to pull through and
create movies that will probably
resonate for generations
they do say everything happens for a
reason if you want more harry potter
videos like this one make sure you hit
that subscribe button
thanks for watching the things